right before crypto crashed i had this
metaverse company hitting me up trying
to pay me a [ __ ] load of money like many
millions of dollars to basically do
metaverse porn with my girl and other
guests or whatever and at first
i'm like you know this sounds stupid as
[ __ ] and then they like keep stressing
i'm like all right you know if this is
how much it's going to pay i will take
some days out of my life to film this
metabolism sure i'll get in the
threesome yeah
well but with like little probes all
over your body and like a green screen
background and all this weird [ __ ] that
we're gonna have to do for the metaverse
thing i think right but then crypto
crash and then they just stopped
emailing me and i was i was kind of
relieved yeah we have a buddy who's uh
close by and not gonna say his name but
because he has the oculus and i'm like
i'm like you ever watch porno on the
oculus he's like dude watching porn on
the oculus and you get you had like like
that dick sucking machine he's like it's
the best experience of all time how do i
not know about this dick sucking machine
yeah like i guess it like just
i don't know you put it over your dick
it's just like
it's like a little machine that just
[ __ ]
i want like a car wash
for my dick like like with little like
brushes and like soap
yeah yeah you could do something like
that because i i mean i i haven't been
in the porn metaverse but my friend a.d
he was saying he went in it and i was
like how was it and he goes it was weird
i had a white dick
he's like he's like looking down at like
a white dick for the first time in his
life in the metaverse which i guess he
maybe just didn't update the shade if
you can do that but yeah that's amazing
i i don't know dude like i i i refuse to
like jerk off with lube or like i i
didn't even like watch porn when i would
jerk off for the longest time i would
just jerk off to my memories and now i
now i watch porn more often i i i had to
stop porn man oh yeah yeah mr addicted
to everything
that's exactly right i haven't i haven't
busted a nut in 130
that's sick no i i just got into therapy
for likes like severe intimacy [ __ ] and
so they're like you should abstain you
know for a certain period of time to
like rewire stuff and then like
they have i i like 60 days i'm like so
could i bust a nut again and they're
like no because you asked and i'm like
what and then i haven't asked and i'm on
like 130 days and i'm just like dude
like i want to ask then i don't want
them to be like
you're not ready because you asked you
haven't had a wet dream [ __ ] no
i used to have wet dreams before i
figured out how to jerk off when i was a
kid i got on my hands and knees like
three days ago and prayed for a wet
dream
i was like dude please just let me just
have a relief i figured out jacking off
way before any goo came out
see i was such a late bloomer i didn't
figure it out until i was like 13 or 14.
oh yeah dude i like um like 12 when i
first jerked off
we had this shower that like oh like
there was like a bathroom that opened up
to the backyard and the swimming pool
and the shower had uh like a foot faucet
to like wash your feet so i i somehow
just figured out that if i crawled
underneath the footballs and put my
wiener under there like uh there was rad
did you have a bathtub
yeah but but it's tough to to crawl
under and and uh get your wiener under
under that faucet
this is this was just somehow worked
really well so i would like be under
that [ __ ] thing
you said you jerked off nine times in
one day i definitely [ __ ] climaxed
with my wiener under that faucet nine
times in one afternoon wow in seventh
grade i've done like five and i thought
that was pretty extreme
yeah but i've only banged five times in
a day i've never even considered
masturbating that many times yeah but
when i when i masturbate like the other
day i jerked off twice before i left the
house and to me like
it felt like i just smoked a bunch of
cigarettes because i don't smoke
cigarettes but like sometimes
if i do it means i'm like kind of in a
degenerate state like the other like
recently i only got like two hours sleep
and i had a full day of interviews and i
[ __ ] bought a pack of cigarettes so i
was just smoking them because it's like
somehow that feels right to me when i'm
like burning the candle at both ends
yeah and that's how i kind of feel about
jerking off like it's like it's like
maintenance in a way because it makes me
like chill the [ __ ] out but then also if
you do it too much it's kind of like
it's just like weird habitual behavior
of like i'm gonna make myself
calm down by doing this stupid thing to
myself over and over i don't know right
you just leave the house your skin's all
oily and you just have shame and i don't
even like doing it i don't boil my dick
up so realistically i might have some
chafing if i were to beat it that many
times
yeah or i could just find some oil
so you and your girl do porn together
yeah so your girl
does porn so she does porn just with me
and uh she mostly just does the only fan
[ __ ] and then we have a show together
called plug talk available at
onlyplugtalk.com where basically we
interview chicks and then we bang them
together and that's what i'm doing right
after this wow dude
today yes do you know who you're going
to bone i do
can you say the name it's like little
quiche
dude that's pretty impressive i mean
that's like uh
an open relationship well but not really
because like i don't [ __ ] with other
girls in my regular life she doesn't
[ __ ] with other guys but we do stuff
with other girls on camera so besides
the content we have a normal monogamous
relationship if you have to like and
only fans get to like like cut next
scene or is it just because it's you're
going to get into the mode you just keep
going you kind of have that decision to
make in general when you're making porn
is like do you want to
do you want to make it all about getting
the best possible image where you
actually like frame up every single shot
like the way they do in a movie and
where you're thinking about the lighting
and you're thinking about like exactly
like making this shot just look as good
as possible or the way we tend to do it
more is like let's just actually have
fun let's make this like closer to us
actually just having a threesome and
maybe every single shot doesn't look
perfect because the cameraman is
capturing you know one of the girls
[ __ ] waddling over to [ __ ] get
into a different position or whatever
but we we try to like err on the side of
it being more real you know that makes
sense to me yeah how did you
start that conversation like what was
the why'd you do it so you know vitaly
yeah vitaly do you have one recently no
but he he he was on roman atwood's place
right yeah he's done a bunch recently so
vitaly i've interviewed and stuff and he
when did you interview vitaly maybe
three years ago or something but it was
right when he started the uncensored
site right right he was doing really
well for himself and so his team was
talking to us and he had been trying to
convince me like you need to do an
x-rated pay site
right but dude he had like i would see
on twitter people saying dude vitali i'm
trying to i can't cancel subscription
i'm trying to keep my subscription and
it won't let me like it was like that
that also makes me glad that i didn't do
that then because okay so the company's
trying to get us to like do
maybe like an x-rated version of the
podcast or whatever and so me and my
girl are talking about it with them and
everything and like over time we start
to be like what the [ __ ] are we gonna
give them a big percentage of it when we
could do all this [ __ ] ourselves like we
know how to hire filmers we know how to
promote we know how to you know like
really we couldn't really think of that
much that they were going to be bringing
to the table and they were put they were
pushing us to go in more of like a
light-hearted like just show the nipples
while we're doing the interview thing
and i'm like that's cool but
realistically
i think that there's a direction that
this is going that like people pay for
porn people pay for podcasts
somebody's gonna do this eventually me
and you both know that we can do it that
we're comfortable having the
conversations and doing the [ __ ] so
why don't we just go for it and so but
but my mentality on it has kind of grown
even from there where now i think of
plug talk as being this overall like
porn media company where i'm trying to
just like make a bunch of cool content
through it in general like right now
we're trying to figure out another
podcast under our network where it's
basically going to be two dudes who
interview a chick and then they [ __ ]
double team the girl together
so it'll be like kind of a different
spin-off on what me and my girl are
doing so i think that there's probably a
bunch of different stuff that we could
kind of do in this world
dude it's epic
i know i was like dude i should put on
pornhub like you know 130 day load and
see like how many downloads it gets and
just see how big the load is dude i
thought about your cell phone
like the the last time i saw you and in
waco and
i i thought to ask you but i was like i
don't want to you know
in case i slipped and it was been
running
it felt like kind of personal like no
that's cool i mean i went on a date last
weekend and it was it was cool like i'm
i'm i got to go on like 10 dates before
i sleep with the chick to like really
get to know somebody that's the rule
you've given yourself
i mean i would like three dates but like
you know i'm in consultation with
somebody and they're like you know
dating plan get to know them and
maybe go to like six to ten dates before
you start engaging sexual because like
my problem is if if i sleep with them on
the first night the sex is really good
and there's just all these red flags
that i'm ignoring and i'm but the sex is
so good i want more then i'm in this
[ __ ] like toxic
cycle with this person you know it's
worse than that because you're you're
attracted to the toxic yeah so like
that's
i prefer the toxic i respect that
because
looking back on my life there was a
bunch of dudes i knew in my life who are
very selective about who they would give
dick to like they were just they were
like good looking guys or guys the girls
liked and they just decided like no i'm
gonna have girlfriends or when i do [ __ ]
a girl randomly it's only gonna be
because i really like her or i really
think she's super hot or whatever and i
went the total opposite way where i was
i was like amazon like i'll [ __ ] any
we'll sell anything i was like [ __ ] it
i'm doing it whatever
and i just wanted the experience i don't
know i just wasn't worried about [ __ ]
some fat girl that i met at the bar like
all right i'm just gonna do it you know
and when i look back at my life i'm like
clearly it would have been better for me
to be a bit more selective but like at
the end of the day with with you and
your girl like um it's not all just sex
like you guys are like best friends or
friends right yeah i mean like that's
important it's like
going hiking together right banging a
different chick together
it's funny though because it's like you
are dealing with like the extreme the
negative like side of like being overly
sexed kind of like with what you're
talking about whereas like a lot of
times people want to ask me like if i
have that kind of relationship with it
and i'm like honestly i feel like doing
this kind of content has given me a way
healthier relationship with sex because
it's just totally demystified it where
it's like once once
banging a bunch of chicks at one time is
like your job for the day and it's just
kind of the thing that you're showing up
and doing that totally just removes this
layer of
i don't know like the way sex just seems
like this thing that you just want so
bad and it's it's so exotic and and
special and fetishized and a lot of that
kind of goes away once you get used to
doing it as a job
yeah i can imagine i mean it's cool to
see you and lux are like best friends
you know like like i want that because
at the end of the day the sex is going
to you're not going to be
like there's different things that
you're going to want to be attracted to
you want to be attracted to spiritually
or emotionally yeah versus just
physically yeah whereas like my problem
is as soon as the like the physical
wears off or like the sexual i'm just
like oh my god i'm over it but if
there's other things that are built
before that i think it's just kind of
you know i don't i don't get in the
relationships for long periods of time
and that's part of the problem right
because as soon as like
like i'm over the sex i'm just like late
right
it's weird for me too now though because
we got a kid
and my girl we want to have another kid
at least one more but then meanwhile my
girl was making all this money on only
fans and we're doing all this content
together and it's like
part of me wants to be like hey
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] like you could just
chill keep pumping out babies i'll make
the money but then like you know it's
like she's kind of wrapped up with like
her sense of self is wrapped up in how
she looks and she doesn't want to
necessarily just like she's kind of torn
because she's like 30 she's like do i
want to do this porn [ __ ] for another
four years and then have a couple kids
or do i want to have another kid right
now and then
get back to doing more content you know
it's kind of like it's it's weirder for
her whereas for me i could just show up
do it and it is what it is you know like
having babies just put such a stress on
a girl's body
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
bestseller my first book's five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude